As you might recall from early on,
one of the things our design calls for
is scrolling of the app bar.
And to do this scrolling, we're going to
make use of a brand new support library
we've created to help
with material design.
The design library.
This library contains tons of stuff to
help you implement material patterns.
It supports all sorts of app bar
buttons, including collapsing
toolbars with floating action buttons,
collapsing toolbars with pinning,
app bar scrolling with pinned list,
parallax scrolling with underscroll,
parallax scrolling with
collapsing app bars.
And it's a lot more than
just app bar pattern,
it also supports things
like navigation views.
Snackbars and floating action buttons,
tab layouts with fixed and
scrolling tabs, and material text
input with collapsing hint texts.
These tools and more open up
the palette for Android developers to
easily implement more material design
And to do so in consistent ways.
The key to how most of this
functionality is implemented
is the CoordinatorLayout.
CoordinatorLayout is part
of the design library,
its basic functionality is
similar to frame layout.
Any views that are placed in
a CoordinatorLayout overlap by default.
You can use layout gravity to
align the views within the layout.
Similar to relative layout, views can
be positioned based upon sibling views,
except in a more limited way.
Gravity can be applied, position of
view center, up, down, left, or right,
with regards to the parent view.
Most interestingly,
CoordinatorLayout supports behavior
classes that can alter the layout.
When we use a snack bar, and
we have a floating action button
inside of a CoordinatorLayout,
the default behavior for
a floating action button will check
to see if there are any overlapping
snack bars and automatically move the
floating action button out of the way.
AppBarLayout is a special
kind of linear layout that
works with CoordinatorLayout to animate
various kinds of toolbar patterns
during nested scrolling
with a sibling view.
Each child of AppBarLayout
takes layout scroll flags,
defined the behavior when nested
scrolling is taking place.
And the sibling to the AppBar is given
the AppBar scrolling view behavior
to coordinate with the AppBar.
So, this is how our AppBar will scroll
of the screen when we scroll our
recycler view.
We add the CollapsingToolbarLayout
to the mix for
some of those really fancy animations.
It allows you some really
complicated transitions.
And the best thing is, you can create
all this complex behavior in XML layouts
without having to touch the code.